Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі Ви знаєте я
хотів говорити про те як сьогодні
Верховна Рада Ну просто втратила свою
суб'єктність Подивіться Сьогодні ми
Приймаємо рішення про призначення
міністра оборони ключове рішення ключова
посада де Президент Президент подав нам
кандидатуру Він навіть не знайшов часу
прийти в Верховну Раду представити
кандидатуру ну це прости елементарна
повага до парламенту і до виборців які
нас сюди обирали ви сьогодні обрали
голову антимонопольного комітету якого
подав уряд нас навіть прем'єр-міністр
сюди вже не ходить всьо раніше коли хоча
приїжджав тридо там я не знаю Санчес
прем'єр-міністр інших країн то з поваги
приходить хоч Мигаль сьогодні вже не
треба всьо Досить вже ми такі нецікаві
що навіть же ж миголюй сюди не цікаво
ходити при тому що це так м'яко кажучи
не самий цікавий Прем'єр в Світі але він
вже не ходить Ну повна неповага обрали
голову антимонопольного комітету
сьогодні тут виступала прем'єр-міністр
Данії Ну може хтось прийде сюди
президент Прем'єр Нема навіть спікер нас
покинув друзі
спікера парламенту і того нема він
поїхав за кордон і відрядження Ну бо
зрозуміло такому можна і я тоді не
розумію А що ми тут з вами робимо а
зараз сесійні залі знаходиться близько
40 депутатів Ми продовжуємо з вами
розгляд рахункова палата ключове питання
40 депутатів і ви знаєте якщо ми самі
себе не поважаємо
якщо ми самі себе не поважаємо То хто
буде нас поважати ми перетворились дуже
поганий аматорський хор Верьовки які
співає пісні і гімн коли хтось до нас
тут приходе скоро будемо виходить з
короваєм Може хтось навчиться Коля
константа навчиться робити Гопака і це
буде наше з вами і роль Друзі Ну це
ганьба це парламент України ми довели
його